welcome to this video playing sis's from
Finland yeah I've played this guy a 4-1
score I have that's not good huh okay
Queens gambit accepted and I hear black
can play Queen to c7 snatching upon a
very greedy approach taking on e3 now is
not doing that aha okay so okay i will
cancel so that i can take d3 later is he
really able to hold this I can take f7
now and 95 isn't this good point okay
check that's kind of weird John Chafee
don't tell me this is some brilliant
trip that she has worked out at home
what the heck is this yeah the night on
g5 I can also play 96 czechia winning
winning the rook in the corner why not
exactly 96 check night XG 497 and I'm
winning the rook yeah come on check a
rookies rookies rook should be enough
and of course he has chances to to trap
the night but it still should be a
really just rook so how to how would you
do it would like to get this this pawn
of course starting with Luke d1 maybe
yeah maybe it's not not totally clear
what the best move order is you cannot
play night before the night is done okay
then years night see two actually but
okay night before I can play night a
three threatening 97 okay I mean I'm a
roo kappa and if he gets the night it's
still an exchange so it should be
totally totally fine
okay so 93 22 a techie form
it goes Knight f6 there is not be 50
maybe just trying to to keep the whole
rock going 497 next there is no reason
really not to do that I think yeah I can
just take am I want to make sure that I
get get both pawns and e4 and III
keep it simple approach so I just take
it right
okay and now I guess bishop p IM 22 ctrl
v4 and so on we should be to rupee one
is very nice and I have everything
nicely covered Bishop c3 is also a
useful idea
and it's really just an exchange in the
pond with nothing special going on yeah
d3 and Bishop g4 so weird combination of
moose
yep let's try to fight against this
piece the bishop is is just wrong
not the only possible way to play with
certainty good okay i can take e 5 for
the check and check on d6 check
yeah let's just double here yeah 95 now
it should be good King e7 is Jackie six
checkmate and here I just go up the
eighth well which yes night xe3 should
take a look take a look first
and
sure that's really not so necessary to a
to lower this a 93 or is this winning
anyway now it's not necessary and my
rook is hanging attention I should pay
attention here okay let's put it him
this was my idea putting it on the
seventh-ranked Luke d6 chance it is
slightly slightly annoying up that I
that I really hell out this kind of
counter play instead of just in exchange
but I think it could have been it could
have been much simpler
yeah one minute but i think i'm able to
double on the seventh-ranked now it
should it should be enough he trades for
winning and get high morning or has to
allow that
check check check I'm b6 is also gone is
that some I don't even see a little
trick or anything chat group b 8 is just
made check for p 8 and the the trade
okay yeah this is off this is the school
of thought that you never resigned when
you still have a night on the board
there is Sir there is some point to that
check check check hmm it's really not
that difficult check check check check
check check check mate yep so long
resistance who ya have it wasn't
probably the most brilliant effort ever
after after I was winning here but ok
guess it was enough to win keeping the
Queen's on is probably the better move
objective but I mean this is just a rook
for the moment and it will always be in
exchange so it is a technical technical
win and they don't say I really allowed
anything here maybe there was something
more convincing some jared's yeah it
always it's always amounts to win I
guess yeah I made a mistake probably
with this check because I intended to
play rook t8 which is really a chat
really stupid so this is better but it
keeps it keeps things so totally under
control Oh s plus 5 and so on yeah this
this whole line is quite interesting in
fact what's what she should I'm sorry
but black normally does is he takes him
and after Bishop takes I get a huge lead
in development like has a pawn so it's
an interesting battle I don't know why
he he didn't do that but d3 is already
weird because it keeps I mean the
development is so bad for black and you
don't need a
now so we had stuff and well Bishop g4s
to say it's just a blunder okay thanks
for watching